à
[Musique]
l'école pop school d'elancourt s'achever
ce vendredi une formation sprint cup de
dix jours cette session a permis à des
personnes en insertion professionnelle
de s'initier à six métiers du numérique
tels que web designers ou encore
développeur internet avec une montée en
puissance d'abord trois métiers par jour
puis ils en choisissent trois qui vont
découvrir sur le reste de la semaine de
façon un peu plus poussée en fait
beaucoup par du partage d'expériences de
professionnels puis en fait pendant une
semaine ils vont réellement pratiqués en
fait didier a quant à lui découvert un
logiciel de community management dans le
but de s'orienter vers la communication
institutionnelle j'ai été aidé parce que
je suis débutant et mais ça se passe
bien les gens sont sympathiques et
accueillants l'ambiance est bonne
intégré au sein du programme ensemble à
100% cette session de formation a permis
aux vingt-sept bénéficiaires parfois
éloignées de l'emploi de retrouver
confiance en eux on se fixe pas comme
ambition forcément que ces gens
s'orientent vers le numérique mais on
utilise plutôt le numérique comme un
levier pour prendre confiance en soi
pour oser pour faire ses recherches
soi-même pour sortir des sentiers battus
on a pris des jacquots des grâces aux
dévoués on a appris bas à modifier
certaines choses
sur les sites internet comment les
manipuler aussi là c'est le site
internet que j'ai créée c'est le site
d'un institut de beauté
c'est le projet qu'on va devoir
présenter vendredi
notre truc chez pop school c'est qu'il
ya pas de prérequis académique vous
pouvez venir sur le bac si vous êtes
motivé et si vous faites preuve d'une
appétence pour les sujets numériques on
va volontiers vous intégrer au même
titre qu'une personne qui a un bac + 3
ou bac + 4 dans une même promo les
élèves ont ensuite la possibilité
d'intégrer un simulateur d'entreprise
pour une durée de deux mois afin de
réaliser des projets plus ambitieux
comme de vrais professionnels
[Musique]